تواصل القتال لليوم الثالث على التوالي
بين اذربيجان وارمينيا وسط تبادل
الاتهامات بين البلدين بمحاوله توسيع رقعه
القتال والسعي الى زعزعه استقرار المنطقه
وياتي هذا وسط دعوات دوليه للطرفين
بضروره وقف القتال والعوده الى الحوار
لايجاد حل سياسي لخلافته
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما دلاله اسرار ارمينيا واذربيجان
على مواصله القتال بينهما وما مدى دقه
اتهاماته المتبادله بمحاوله توسيع رقعه
القتال وما هي فرص استجابه باكو وارفان
لدعوات وقف القتال واللجوء للحوار
والدبلوماسيه من اجل حل
خلافاتهما
[موسيقى]
لليوم الثالث على التوالي اذا تواصل
القتال بين اذربيجان
وارمينيا على اقليم كارباخ وزاره الخارجيه
الارمينيه اتهمت باكو بتحضير ما سمتها
رقعه عملياتها العسكريه
العدائيه وصفتها بخطوات اذربيجان لزعزع
لاستقرار في المنطقه على الجهه الاخرى وفي
السياق ذاته اكدت وزاره الدفاع
الاذربيجانيه ان القوات الارمينيه حاولت
التقدم باتجاه المواقع
الاذربيجانيه في جبهتي فوزو وجبرائيل قبل
ان تتصدى لها القوات
الاذربيجانيه وتدمر اربع دبابات وتوقع نحو
عشره جنود بين قتيل وجريح وتجبرها على
التراجع وفق
الوزاره
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
جوتيريش دعى اذربيجان وارمينيا الى وقف
اطلاق النار وحث رئيسيه ما على تهدئه
التوتر والعوده الى المفاوضات دعوه تعضد
نداء موسكو الذي وجهته الى جميع شركائها
خصوصا تركيا من اجل بدل قصاره جهدها
لاقناع الاطراف المتحاربه في كارباخ وقف
اطلاق النار والعوده الى ما سمتها تسويه
سلميه بالوسائل السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه الرئاسه الروسيه اكدت في
بيان لها ان موسكو على تواصل مستمر مع
انقره وفان وباكو على مختلف المستويات
بشان تطورات الوضع في كارباخ واضافت ان
موقف موسكو الذي وصفته
بالمتواتر باخ يسمح لها بلعب بدور الوساطه
لتسويه النزاع واضاف البيان ان اي تصريحات
عن تقديم دعم عسكري لاحد اطراف النزاع في
كارباخ تصب الزيت على النار وان موسكو
ترفض مثل هذه التصريحات
بشده تركيا من جهتها اكدت على لسان وزير
خارجيتها مولوت شاا وشوجو ان الحل الوحيد
لمشكله اقليم كارباخ هو انسحاب ارمينيا من
الاراضي الاذربيجانيه التي احتلتها اما
ايران الجار الثالثه المعنيه بالقتال بين
ارمينيا واذربيجان فقد اكدت انها تتابع
بدقه وقلق التوتر في كارباخ وتعهدت ببدل
كل ما تستطيع لتحقيق السلام بين باكو
وفان مسائل منطق نراقب بدقه وقلق ما يقع
بين اذربيجان وارمينيا ونعتقد انه يمكنهما
التوصل الى تفاهم ايران لن تدخر جهدا
لتحقيق السلم والاستقرار في هذه المنطقه
وتؤكد دائما على ضروره احترام وحده اراضي
الدول وسيادتها وفق القوانين الدوليه
وقرارات الامم المتحده الخلاف بين
الدولتين له حل سلمي وسياسي ويمكننا مع
دول الجوار ان نساعد اذربيجان وارمينيا في
تطبيق قرارات الامم
المتحده هذا الصباح تحدثت هاتفيا مع وزير
الخارجيه الالماني وتناولنا التط الاخيره
ومشكله كارباخ كما تناولنا الاعتداءات
الارمينيه واصلنا للطرف الالماني الرسائل
اللازمه واخبرنا كيف يجب ان يكون حل مساله
كارباخ ليس هناك سوى حل واحد هو انسحاب
ارمينيا من الاراضي الاذربيجانيه التي
احتلتها ان لم تنسحب ارمينيا فان المساله
لن تحل قرارات الامم المتحده والمجلس
الاوروبي ومنظمه الامن والتعاون الاوروبيه
بشان وحده التراب الاذربيجاني واضحه لكن
وعلى الرغم من كل هذه القرارات فان مجموعه
دول منسك الثلاث والمنظمه نفسها لم تخطو
باتجاه حل ملموس للمشكله نريد حل المشكله
بشكل ملموس بالطرق
السلميه ومناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من باكو عبر الانترنت روفيز حافظ اوجلو
رئيس تحرير وكاله ترند للانباء
الاذربيجانيه ومن يريفان عبر الانترنت
ايضا ينضم الينا هوف هانز نيكو جوزيان
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بالجامعه
الامريكيه في ارمينيا وينضم الينا من هنا
من الدوحه عبر الانترنت ايضا الدكتور
ابراهيم فريحات استاذ النزاعات الدوليه في
معهد الدوحه للدراسات العليا ارحب بكم
جميعا في هذه الحلقه وابدا معك في ريفان
السيد نيكو جوزيان طبعا هذا ثالث يوم من
القتال في اسوا موجه من القتال منذ
تسعنيات القرن الماضي مع ارتفاع حصيله
الضحايا من
المدنيين ما دلالات الاصرار من الطرفين
طبعا على مواصله القتال بل وتوسيع دائره
القتال الاستضافه والامر يتعلق طبعا بموجه
مواجهه كما تفضلت وهي الاسوا منذ فتره
الان تحولت الامور الى حرب تتوسع شيئا
فشيئا وفي ال 27 من سبتمبر انطلقت هذه
المواجهات وهناك عدد كبير من الضحايا من
بينهم ايضا مجموعه من المدنيين وهناك
استهداف بشكل مباشر لاهداف مدنيه من قبل
اذربيجان في التراب الارماني وحدث هذا
ايضا هذا اليوم واعتقد ان هذا عمل
يحاول ريون من خلاله جر ارمينيا الى حرب
ايضا تركيا انضمت الى الحرب تركيا لم تعد
طرفا موحدا وفي حقيقه الامر تركيا لم تكن
قط طرفا محايدا في هذا النزاع وتركيا ما
فتئت تقدم الدعم الجوي لاذربيجان
وتم تزويد ايضا اذربيجان بالطائرات
ومقاتلات اف 16
والقوات الارمينيه قامت ب اسقاط الطائرات
اذا هذا يوسع من رقعه المواجهه التي قد
تمتد نعم اذا سيد
روفيع تمتد الى روسيا ايضا وتنضم روسيا
الكره واضحه سيد روفيز هل فعلا هذا هو
السبب وراء استمرار القتال بهذا العنف
لليوم الثالث على
التوالي على دعواتكم سيده خديجه لكن هناك
يعني ضيفكم من ارمينيا لا يتكلم يعني
بالوضوح لانه هذه الاراضي المشكل كما تعلم
كما يعلم كل العالم فانها اراضي
الاذربيجانيه ونحن كشعب اذربيجاني لقد
صبرنا اكثر من 30 سنه هل هناك وهذا الحرب
يعني هجوم شامل على المواقع الجيش
الارماني بدات
بعد هجوم يعني نحن رد الفعل يعني على
ارمينيا فالضيف كم من روان يقول ان هناك
تدخل التركي انا الانسان عدو ما يجهل
ضيفكم لا يعلم عن اي شيء عن اذربيجان وعن
الجيش الاذربيجاني عن موقف الاذربيجاني في
المنطقه ويقول ان هناك التركيا تدعم
اذربيجان ب طائرات الاف 16 هذا كلام فار
اليوم كما تعلمون رسور نعم هل هذا غير
صحيح وتركيا تلقي بثقلها بشكل كامل وراء
اذربيجان سياسيا وعسكريا انا سارد على
سؤالك لو انا سارد على سؤالك لو سمحت يعني
اول شيء هناك تركيا لا لن ترسل الى
اذربيجان طائرات مقاتلات سف 16 وهناك لم
يسقط اي
طائره التركيه في المنطقه كما يي ضيف من
ارمينيا فما يخوص دعم تركي لاذربيجان هذا
الدعم معنوي نعم اليوم وزير الخارجيه
التركيه يقول انه نحن مع شعب اذربيجاني
فاي كان يعني اذا اذربيجان شعب اذربيجاني
اختر طريق الحرب نحن سنكون معهم من في
ميدان اذا اختاروا طريقه السلام التي نحن
لا نصدق بسبب انه ما نرى اي نتيجه من هذه
المفاوضات سلام لانه 30 سنه مجموعه منسك
لا تفل اي
شيء روسيا التي كانت تملك مفاتيح السلام
عندها في يدها موسكو لم تستفد من
هذه مفاتيح السلام ماذا قدك ولكن نعم نعم
ولكن ولكن ضيفنا من يريفان هوفان نيكو
جوزيان يهز راسه اعتراضا على كلامك ساعود
اليه ولكن انتقل الى الدكتور ابراهيم
فريحات برايك دكتور ابراهيم فريحات ما هي
حسابات ايه كل طرف من وراء هذا القتال
ا يعني شكرا للاستضافه ولضيفك في اذربيجان
وارمينيا باعتقادي يعني المساله الاولى هي
بالنسبه الى اذربيجان ان لديها اراضي
محتله منذ نها منذ ال 94 منذ انتهاء الحرب
الماضيه وهذا شكل ضغط كبير جدا على
اذربيجان بان بان هناك انعدام بالحل
السياسي ا بعد انتهاء الحرب وتشكيل مجموعه
المنكس جروب التي كان يفترض ان تكوم
بعمليه وساطه وتفاوض ما بين
الاطى
ال بكل تاكيد يعني مشكله المنس جروب ان
يعني يفترض ان تقوم ان بعمليه تفاوضيه
ولكن هناك عمليه سلام بدون سلام وعمليه
تفاوض بدون تفاوض ففشلت على مدار اكثر من
25 عام هذه المجموعه التي تتراس بالمناسبه
الولايات الم المتحده
وروسيا يعني طيب دعنا نقل الحديث عن
الجهود السياسيه الى المحور الثاني
ومجموعه منسك طبعا ضمن يعني منظمه الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا نرحل الى النقاش حول
الحلول والمفاوضات والدعوات الى وقف
القتال لكن الان دكتور فريحات من الذي
يغذي برايك هذا الصراع وهذا القتال هل هي
فقط اجنده محليه ام اكثر من ذلك
هناك يعني هذا الصراع لا يدور بفراغ خديجه
هناك فعلا يعني احباط على المستويين
الاذربيجاني والارمي الاذربيجاني لان
اراضيه محتله ولان هناك لاجئين من نهايه
التسعينيات حوالي مليون لاجئ اللي هجرتهم
الحرب من سواء كان من اقليم ناغورنو
كارباخ او من الاراضي اللي احتلت الاضافيه
فيما بعد ذلك ايضا هناك احباط على مستوى
ارمينيا وعلاقتها من مع روسيا ب هذا
الموضوع هذا الموضوع هناك اطراف اقليميه
متداخله فيه بشكل كبير تركيا اعلنت من
اليوم الاول وجودها الى جانب اذربيجان
ايضا ايران تدعم ارمينيا بهذا الصراع
تاريخيا اي وناك مجموعه من الاسباب ايضا
اذربيجان هناك لها علاقات ايضا مع اسرائيل
وهو هذا بالنسبه الى ايران ايضا خط احمر
وهناك ايضا النموذج خديجه التركي الروسي
الذي يفترض اللي هو على على غرار نموذج
الاستانه مفاوضات الاستانه والترتيبات
الليبيه التي بدا هذا التنافس او الصراع
التركي الروسي ايضا ينسحب على مناطق صراع
اخرى ومنها هنا ايضا نلاحظ ان هناك هذه
الديناميات الصراع هي اصبحت تتبلور في هذه
المنطقه بشكل واضح تماما فهل يعني من
المتوقع ان يكون في استانه ثانيه اللي هي
الى هذه المنطقه يعني روسيا وتركيا هي
اطراف رئيسيه في هذا الموضوع ايضا هناك
عامل اللي هو النفط الذي تصدره اذربيجان
من خلال جورجيا الى تركيا وتركيا تصدر الى
اوروبا وهذا يشكل خطر كبير او منافسه
كبيره بالنسبه الى روسيا بهذا الاتجاه
ولهذا السبب يعني تحاول ايضا روسيا عرقلت
هذا الموضوع على اعتبار استقلال الطاقه ما
بين اللي هو اذربيجان وتركيا وامدادات
الاوروبيه على حساب النفط الروسي بهذا
الاتجاه فاذا العوامل هي جميعها مت داخله
ولا يمكن فصل احد عن الاخر ولكن طبعا يجب
ان تبنى هذه التدخلات الاقليميه على مشكله
والمشكله هي موجوده ما بين ارمينيا
واذربيجان التي تحولت الى ساحه معركه او
باتل جراوند للصراعات الاقليميه المت
معركه نعم يعني ساحه معركه وهذا ليس جديدا
استاذ هوفز نيكو جوزيان يعني هذه ساحه
المعركه هذه مفتوحه من زمان يعني جربوا
الحلول السياسيه وقعت هدنه سنه
994 ولم تؤدي الى شيء في النهايه كما شرح
قبل قليل الدكتور ابراهيم فريحات في
النهايه هذه ارض يعني كارباخ منطقه تقع
داخل اراضي اذربيجان تسكنها اغلبيه ارمنيه
ومدعومه من ارمينيا المجاوره نحن نتحدث عن
ارض بالاساس هي اذربيجانيه ما الذي يؤخر
الحلول حتى الان
برايك
بدايه ضيفكم من الدوحه وباكو يقومون
بالكثير من الدعايه المغلوطه و انا لن
انضم اليكم لهذا البرنامج لامضي في هذا
الخصوص الحليب يبقى ابيضا بغض النظر عن
زاويه النظر اليه كما يقال عندنا اذا هناك
كما تعرفون اباده للارمي لم ازد 100 سنه
من قبل اتراك واتراك كانوا دائما يرفضون
هذا الامر
اذا بقيه العالم تقول شيئا مغايرا وتنظر
الى المساله بعين مختلفه وهناك مجموعه من
الدول اتخذت قرارات واضحه حيال هذا الامر
تركيا واذربيجان طبعا ترفض ان تعترف
بمخططاتها لقتل الكثير من الارمن لذلك
هناك ض لكل دعوات مرتبطه بوقف اطلاق النار
واطلاق عمليه سياسيه
للاسف نرى
بان الكثير من الاصوات وايضا في هذا
البرنامج اصوات تلوح بالحرب ضيفكم من باكو
يتحدث عن الصابر نعم في
1994 اذربيجان طلبت بتوقيع اتفاقيه وقف
اطلاق النار وتم ذلك ب فضل وساطه روسيا
واستمرت المفاوضات منذ ذلك الوقت نعم كان
هناك صعود وهبوط طوال فتره ال 26 سنه
الماضيه ولكن لم يتم التوصل الى حلول
واضحه لان اذربيجان كانت دائما تقفز من
العمليه السياسيه ومن المفاوضات وتخرق
الاتفاقات التي تم الوصول اليها اخر مره
حصل ذلك كان قبل سنه وكان في ذلك الوقت
ايضا هم وسط ضيفكم من باكو وضيفكم من
الدوحه يزعمان بان هناك ضغط الرئيس علي في
تصور الضغط لن يكون نجح الا في الدول
الديمقراطيه واذربيجان ليست ديمقراطيه
وتركيا ايضا ليست دوله ديمقراطيه الضغط
بشكل عام اعتقد هذه فقط سرديه لا تجدي
نفعا ولا تقود الى حلول واضحه وللاسف بعض
المؤسسات الاعلاميه ايضا تمضي في نفس الخط
وكنت اتمنى ان يكون ضيفكم من ال ترك لك
الوقت الكافي نعم وقد تركنا لك الوقت
الكافي لتعبر عن وجهه نظرك وترد هذا حقك
ولكن دعني انتقل الى روفيز حافظ اوجلو
يعني واضح من كلام نيكو جوزيان يعني يلمح
ليس مش فقط يلمح يصر على انه الدور التركي
والثقل تركيا يعطل الحل خل لنا نعود الى
ما قاله وزير خارجيه تركيا مولود شاو شوجو
يقول نقف الى جانب اخواننا الاذربيجاني في
القتال وعلى طاوله الحوار هذا يسهل الحل
ام يعطل الحل تصريحات
كهذه اول شيء يا السيده خديج لو سمحت يعني
الشخص الذي يتكلم عن السلام يعني انا سارد
على اسئلتكم وانا بفهم انه الوقت ضيق جدا
ف الدوله التي تتكلم عن السلام وتتهم
اذربيجان بانها لا تريد السلام هل ممكن
تريني في في اذربيجان في ارمينيا اي واحد
اذربيجاني هناك الاف من اذربيجاني تركوا
ارمينيا و جاؤوا الى الى اذربيجان نحن
احصائيه عندنا موجوده ان في
بلدنا على الاقل في باكو في العاصمه 20 ال
من المواطنين الارمن يعني هم اصولهم ارمن
يعيشون في ا ا غير ذلك يعني الدوله التي
تتكلم عن السلام اين منطقكم اين يعني
دلائل عن السلام يعني انتم قتلتم قريه
واحده مدينه واحده دمرتم مدينه واحده في
اللي واحده وهي منطقه خوجالي والشخص
وضيفكم من يرمان يقول ان الوله غير
ديمقراطيه وكن هذا ليس
موضوعنا سيد حفي اجلو هذا ليس موضوعنا نعم
يعني الحلقه ليست للرد على على على ضيفنا
من يرفان ولكن نتحدث عن جهود السلام في
هذا المحور الثاني هناك دعوات هناك دعوه
من جوتيريش الامين العام للامم المتحده
للتهدئه هناك دعوه من روسيا ايضا تدعو
ايضا الطرفين وحتى توسع الدعوه الى شركاء
الطرفين ايضا ل الدفع بالتهدئة
انها تريد سلام الدوله التي تريد سلام
عليها ان تخرج من هذه الاراضي
الاذربيجانيه
كل العالم يقول ان الكاربا خ المحتله
الامر لا تخص فقط كارباخ هناك سبعه مدن
محتله وهي اراض اذربيجانيه يعني لما نحن
نتكلم عن اذربيجان او كارباخ الجبليه كل
العالم يعترف ان هذه الاراضي الاذربيجانيه
فلا خلافه في ذلك حتى ارمينيا لن تعترف
حتى الان ارتساخ ما يسمى ارخ كدوله مستقله
فع ماذا يتكلم ضيفنا من ضيفكم من روان عن
ماذا يتكلم المشكله الوحيده امام السلام
لا تعترف باستقلال كارباخ تقصد ابدا
ارمينيا لا تعترف حتى الان لا تعترف بدوله
كارباخ وليس هناك اي دوله في العالم تعترف
باستقلالها ابدا ابدا لا تعترف اي دوله
حتى وان كانت ايران التي نحن نعلم في
اذربيجان انها تدعم
وهي دوله مهمه بالنسبه ثمانيا حتى ايران
لم تعترف
طيب على ذكر ايران على ذكر ايران والسؤال
لدكتور ابراهيم فريحات المتحدث باسم
الحكومه الايرانيه قال الحل في كارباخ هو
حل سياسي وفق القانون الدولي ونحن مستعدون
لتسهيل الحلول والحوار هل هذا يمكن ان
يدفع ربما
بالحوار ومفاوضات السلام خصوصا وانت تحدثت
في في في جوابك الاول دكتور على انه يعني
منظم او مجموعه منسك مغيبه تقريبا وتراس
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي جهودها
يعني تاتي ضمن منظمه التعاون والامن في
اوروبا ولكنها مغيبه على اي جهود يمكن
الاعتماد لتسهيل
الحوار يعني بخصوص مجموعه المنسك واذا
سمحتي لي بس بملاحظه سريعه لضيفك من يرفان
انا حقيقه يعني لا افهم ما هو سر احتجاجه
وهذه الحديه التي هو في عليها يعني نحن
نتحدث عن ان مجموعه المنسك هي فشلت من منذ
ال 94 حتى الان بايجاد حل حل سلبي للصراع
هذه يا سيدي العزيز حقيقه موضوعيه هي ليست
خاطئه لا للتحليل ولا ل الى اخره يعني
وليس فقط في ارمينيا واذربيجان ارني اي
نموذج في العالم التي يعني استطاعت رئاسه
امريكيه روسيه كما هو الحال في مجموعه
المنس جروب ان تتوصل الى حل سواء في سوريا
او في ليبيا او في اي مكان اخر فالمس هو
ليس حص ليس حكرا على ارمينيا واذربيجان
هذا الذي يعني الموضوع تحدث نعم بنقطه
مهمه اعتقد يجب الالتفات لها وهي يعني
معروفه من جذور الصراع ان الصراع يعني هو
بالاصل
ايضا ارميني تركي يعود جذوره التاريخيه
منذ الحرب العالميه الاولى والى اخره هذا
لا لا احد ينكر هذا الموضوع ولهذا السبب
لا اعتقد انه يجب ان نغفل حقيقه فشل
مجموعه الانسو وانا اكرر هذا الاتجاه ويجب
من اجل الخروج من هذه المعضله اللي هو
باعاده ولاجابه على سؤالك خديجه اعاده
النظر في المان ديت التفويض الذي يوجد
لهذه المجموعه والتي تشترك فيها فرنسا
ايضا والى اي حد ان يكون هناك هي احتكرت
العمليه التفاوضيه والعمليه الوساطه لهذا
الصراع كما حدث عندما احتكرت الولايات
المتحده عمليه الوساطه في الصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي واستمر ايضا من ال
93 حتى هذه اللحظه ولم تتوصل الى نتيجه
يجب سحب البساط من تحت اللي هي اقدام
الوسطاء الدوليين عندما يفشلون في اي
وساطه في صراع من هذه الصراعات لا ان تبقى
هذه الدول تدفع ثمن فشل هذه المجموعه وهو
كما يحدث في الوقت الحالي وهذه الحرب التي
قامت الان هي نتيجه التي يدفع ثمنها الضيف
ارمينيا من من ارمينيا وايضا في اذربيجان
يدفعوا ثمن هذا الفشل الروسي الامريكي
والتنافس الامريكي الروسي في هذا الموضوع
كما هو في بقيه الصراعات للاجابه بس اذا
سمحتي لي على الموضوع الايراني موضوع
ايران يعني هي بحاجه ان تلعب دور يمكنها
ان تلعب دور اكثر ايجابيه لانها لديها
تواصل مع الطرفين رغم التحفظات الايرانيه
على علاقه اذربيجان مع اسرائيل والامور هذ
في كلمتين نيكو جوزيان كيف ترى
الحل
انا اتفق جزئيا مع ضيفكم في الدوحه في
شيئين في حقيقه
الامر مجموعه مينسك يجب ان تتغير وتوليفات
المجموعه يجب ان تتغير
وبوقت الذي نتحدث فيه هناك ايضا دور يطلع
به مجلس الامن الدولي في هذه المساله
وستكون هناك جلسه بهذا الخصوص بالتالي
ضروري ازاله تركيا من هذه المجموعه مجموعه
مسكف ويجب ان يمحى اسم تركيا في المستقبل
من هذه المجموعه لان تركيا ليست وسيطا الى
غايه الان نعرف ان تركيا هي طرف في هذا
هذه الحرب
الان اداره ثنائيه في كلمتين ايضا حفيدو
كيف ترى الحل
انس
حل الوحيد
ا عليها ان تخرج من اراضي المحتله
الاذربيجانيه حل الوحيد ارمينيا عليها ان
تخرج من اراضي المحتله الاذربيجانيه بس
فما يخص انها حذف تركيا من من مجموعه مسك
يعني هي تركيا ما كانت مكلفه ان تحيل قضيه
كارباخ الجبليه هناك ثلاثه دول واحد
دوله روسيه ثانيا هي فرنسا والولايات
المتحده يعني تركيا ما كانت في هذه
القائمه لذلك
بصح ل ضيفكم من ارمينيا كما اقول الحل
الاساسي يعني على ارمينيا عليها ان تخرج
من اراضي المحتله الاذربيجانيه ثم نجلس
على الولت ونحن كما اذربيجان قلنا لهم انه
نحن قادرين ان نعطي لكم حكم الذاتي لكن
ارمينيا اسف الشديد لا تريد السلام وشعب
الاذر ارمينيا اسف الشديد اسير فيما تجري
في
الميدان طيب نعم تصحيحا لما قاله اذا
ضيفنا من يريفان المجموعه تضم روسيا
وفرنسا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا
تضم تركيا كما قال بهذا ناتي مشاهدينا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه لا يسعنا في الاخير الا
ان نشكر ضيفنا من باكو رفيس حفيظ اوجلو
وضيفنا من يريفان هوفز نيكو جوزيان وضيفنا
من الدوحه الدكتور ابراهيم
فريحات نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد لكم مننا اطيب المنى
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا